in this episode of cloud performance
atlas we help some DNA technicians
improve their upload speeds while they
get the folds out of their genome before
their big meeting stay tuned to find out
DNA soap is a biotech company whose main
product is a software that does protein
folding across distributed machines
sadly though anytime they would provide
a new data set to be worked on there was
a significant delay before any clients
would start doing computation their
architecture was pretty straightforward
once a new genome data set came in it
would get chopped up and uploaded to
Google Cloud storage where clients who
were listening for pub/sub updates would
grab the work blocks and start computing
now here's the interesting part the size
of the work blocks change depending on
how many connected clients there were to
do the work so more workers resulted in
smaller work blocks to balance out
properly the problem at hand was that
the DNA soaps software was taking a
really long time to upload all the files
to GCS in regions with a really high
number of available workers to try and
replicate this I created a small Python
script which generated files of various
sizes and then uploaded each file to a
GCS regional bucket about a hundred
times or so turns out the smaller the
files in your set this slower your
upload speed the reason for this is that
there's a certain amount of
transactional overhead for uploading
files so the smaller they are the more
this overhead adds up the solution
parallel uploads gsutil provides the - M
option which performs parallel copy
which can significantly increase the
performance of an upload when we chart
the performance against our base state
we can see that the parallel version
provides significantly higher throughput
since the transactional overhead is
mitigated across many threads for DNA
soap this small command line flag
resulted in a 2x improvement in upload
speed for their files not bad for a
bunch of scientists if you want to know
more about parallel uploads check out
the associated article listed in the
description below and don't forget to
check out the rest of our cloud
performance Atlas content when it comes
to performance every millisecond counts